president putin
recently
you ordered your troops into ukraine
which is a sovereign nation
and this was a mistake
you underestimated the capability
and the fighting spirit of the brave
ukrainian people
and that's understandable
my country
made that same mistake
in vietnam
in iraq
and in afghanistan
these mistakes
led to drawn out conflicts
that depleted our finances
our materials
and cost us much of our most precious
resource of all
american blood
your country
has made that same mistake in the past
as well
in afghanistan
and more recently
in chechnya
now you have made that same mistake
again but you have also made another
mistake
you misjudged
the international community
who
has universally condemned your actions
you have been
cut off financially
your supply chain has been severed
you are standing alone from a military
perspective you will receive no support
yet on the contrary
your enemy
the free people of ukraine
are going to receive an unlimited supply
of weapons
ammunition fuel food
and troops
from nations around the world
this will be a war of attrition
against the most well-supported freedom
fighters the world has ever seen
and you will lose
that is the reality
but i don't want that
i do not want war i do not want
suffering
and i don't want to see
our once great ally the russian people
consumed
by the devastation of war
so
i am solemnly requesting
that you immediately correct this
mistake by withdrawing all your troops
from ukraine starting within the next 48
hours
if you do so
i will personally see to it
that there are no further ramifications
against your country
i will find a way to negotiate a
peaceful agreement with ukraine that
addresses your concerns and finally
i will help
rebuild your infrastructure
and i will support actions that will
help to rebuild your economy
this is a generous offer to your nation
a nation
with a history of great strength
a nation who we once
stood side by side with
to defeat the evil third reich
i hope
you accept
this request for peace
but
if you do not comply
there will be consequences
i have been to war
and i do not like it
but i know how to wage it
12 hours ago i gave an order sending
three aircraft carrier battle groups to
the vicinity
i also gave the order for the deployment
of 50 000 combat ready soldiers sailors
airmen and marines to our nato allies
bordering ukraine
these include
surface-to-air and surface-to-surface
missile systems
it includes combat aviation and aviation
support teams
and it also includes medical
logistics infantry and special
operations units
the united states of america will bring
the full spectrum of lethal warfare to
the battlefield
that being said we will not get into a
ground war with you
america does not need to
the brave ukrainian men and women will
fight for their own
country
history tells us of their courage
and they are already proving their medal
in battle once again
but with our technological capabilities
and assets are eminently prepared troops
and our partnerships with allies and the
undaunted ukrainian people on the ground
i promise you
your aircraft will be
destroyed your missile systems will be
destroyed
all of your tanks and armored fighting
vehicles will be destroyed
your naval vessels in proximity of the
conflict will be destroyed
and many of your fine soldiers and
sailors will be killed
it will be a devastating loss
and your country's military
and economy
will take years to rebuild
but i don't want that
my generation of americans have been at
war for two decades we don't want war
we want peace
for russia
for ukraine for europe and for the world
so please carefully consider my offer
withdraw your troops
and let's move forward together
in a positive way
that avoids further war and bloodshed
and brings peace and prosperity to the
world
the choice is yours
i am standing by for your reply